friday edition of p-f-t-o-t
and chris sims all the buttons button
again but well i you know the bet was
only for the two hours so you are
allowed to go buttoned for pft ot thank
you boss it this literally is pftot
because we tripped onto something in our
final seconds literally on the air on
friday and we almost ran out of time
talking it through so let's continue
with the thing that popped into my head
as we were talking about the saints back
up quarterback situation taysom hill has
looked better than teddy bridgewater so
far this preseason the panthers in the
same division have a specific need if
cam newton has an injury that will last
into the regular season the back up
quarterback positions in carolina not
stellar
teddy bridgewater has the connection to
norv turner who was the offensive
coordinator for the first two years the
teddy bridgewater was in minnesota could
it be that the saints and the panthers
would do a trade for teddy bridgewater
you know the eagles in washington once
did a trade for donovan mcnabb so it's
not unprecedented the bills and the
patriots right where did drew bledsoe go
after he was supplanted by tom brady he
went to buffalo yeah so i hey if the
price is right the saints would do it i
would think especially if it gives sean
payton an easy way out of a difficult
spot where it becomes clear that taysom
hill is the better option than teddy
bridgewater so i i i think that it's not
something that we should scoff at i i'm
with you i mean uh you we you stumbled
upon it it was great thought by you i
hear you all the way uh we talked a lot
about about the panthers back up
quarterback situation's scary it really
is and that's not an indictment on will
greer he could be a fine player going
into the future the the facts of the
situation are he's young uh
he's young he came from an offense that
was a spread offense and he's
orchestrating a different offense now
kyle allen's certainly not going to give
you the confidence that he can just take
over the reins and go with it from there
this is the thing
i look at mike right and i'm just trying
to put myself in like sean payton's
shoes taysom hill uh certainly looks
better than teddy bridgewater to me and
especially last week and i know
bridgewater was sick and all that will
give him the benefit of the doubt to a
degree i'm going to to a degree
but
if you make taysom hill the backup
quarterback right
they need to find somebody else too in
new orleans because
or they have to stop doing the taysom
hill gadget plays and he can't play on
special teams and do that they'll have
to maybe reorganize or do something like
that yeah you got to protect him at that
point because if he gets injured then
you're screwed right right so that just
the one thing that pops through my brain
there when i go okay so if the saints
are gonna do that then they better get
started on a guy that they can sign to
feel okay he can be our backup in case
taysom hill you know gets a ding
shoulder when he's running up the middle
on a power run play or something like
that but uh either way i think carolina
needs to exhaust all options on this one
if it gets to that point
and and if there's that opportunity
there for teddy bridgewater to play and
he desperately wants to play you know
and again we don't know how serious the
cam newton injury is but
you could have a clamoring from
bridgewater and a request from
bridgewater to let me go to a team that
will let me play much like adrian
peterson two years ago in in new orleans
when he was unhappy with his role
eventually they found a trading partner
for him all right uh maybe a trading
partner will be necessary for brian
hoyer out of new england because chris
you've seen some indications based upon
pre-season rep distribution that maybe
jared stidham the rookie from auburn is
in the process of leapfrogging hoyer as
the number two guy behind tom brady i do
think you know signs are there i mean
first off stidhum as you've seen mike
has been really impressive i mean he has
and uh you know doesn't get the
attention maybe daniel jones does
because he wasn't the sixth pick of the
draft but really uh upping that type of
conversation for me for what he's done
and how he looks and some of the quality
of the throws and decisions he's made
the fact that he came in last night
after brady and got to play with the
ones and do all that just made me think
that yeah maybe they are setting it up
or think he can realistically be the
backup and they wanted to see how he can
handle that situation i don't know if
that means they only keep two
quarterbacks uh and maybe they let hoyer
go or do something that maybe hoyer
becomes trade bait for the carolina
panthers now that i'm sitting here
thinking about it but either way stidhum
i do think is impressed enough to where
the patriots are certainly thinking
about making him the backup for this
season
bill belichick was asked after the game
what went into the decision to not play
brian hoyer and give all those extra
reps to jared stidham and belichick in
his typical candid fashion we do what we
think is best for the team we take a
look at everybody brian's played a lot
of football so they know what they have
in brian hoyer
and they're trying to figure out what
they have in jared stidham and maybe
they have enough that he could be the
number two guy and you're right it does
put hoyer in play to be traded somewhere
and hoyer is a guy he's almost like josh
mccown light right he's been on a bunch
of different teams right he's never you
know and it seems like every time he has
a chance to play he gets a concussion he
gets injured something happens remember
when the browns felt like they were
having their rebirth a few years ago and
hoyer who is from that area suffered a
torn acl on a thursday night i mean
there's just you know there's always
something that happens when brian hoyer
gets his chance but maybe there's going
to be an opportunity somewhere else one
place where there won't be an
opportunity for brian hoyer or teddy
bridgewater or colin kaepernick the
miami dolphins because they have two
guys they're trying to figure out which
one will be the starting quarterback
between ryan fitzpatrick and josh rosen
what do you see so far i mean i i think
there's going to be a situation where
whoever wins the job week one is
eventually going to get benched and then
that guy's going to get punched and then
the first guy is going to get a rebound
they're going to be banging back and
forth between fitzpatrick and rosen all
year yeah it wasn't it hasn't been
pretty uh at moments for either one of
these quarterbacks and last night
especially in the first half of ryan
fitzpatrick it was not good i mean they
can't feel great about that situation
and the way the offense has looked to
this point but yeah there's been no
clear-cut winner uh as far as oh this
guy's put their stamp i'm gonna be the
starting quarterback i do think rosen
shows more potential to be big time and
some of the plays and throws he makes i
i definitely do see that but it might be
one of those situations mike where you
bring it up you're right we might be
going back and forth or a little bit i
think if it's even close or if even
rosen just barely has the lead i think i
would start ryan fitzpatrick knowing
that at some point we're gonna throw
josh rosen in there and he's gonna get a
chance to really show what he has uh
this is a guy that they're they're
hoping can maybe be the franchise guy in
the future and maybe you don't want to
just throw them out there in week one a
guy who's in his second nfl team second
year second system you know ucla changed
coaches when he was there he had a deal
with that as well to where maybe they
don't want to throw him out in the fire
early on let ryan fitzpatrick take some
of the lumps get the team organized a
little bit and see what direction
they're going and then you throw josh
rosen in
the fact that rosen hasn't come in and
taken over right yeah i think that that
already tells us
what we need to know about the future of
the quarterback position in miami this
is a one-year experiment with
fitzpatrick and rosen rosen and
fitzpatrick now rosen could stick around
as the backup after this year he's got
an affordable contract but i think the
signs are now pointing toward miami
doing something in 2020 that doesn't
involve one of those two guys being the
starter yeah i i think that's fair at
this point i i do think rosen will have
one last say in the matter right uh
where he'll get a chance and if he can
if he can blow the doors off to where
they go damn okay this guy you know he's
better than we thought and he's throwing
balls all around the field and making
good decisions then maybe he can do that
the one thing i look at with with their
situation too and i know we talk about
this a lot their early season schedule
mike it is brutal it's ravens patriots
at the cowboys and then the chargers and
that's that's tough that's why i
probably air on ryan fitzpatrick knowing
hey we're not going to the super bowl
this year we're a team that's in total
rebuild mode maybe we just let
fitzpatrick get out there take some
lumps gonna get us going and then you
get a rosin in there and see what he's
got
yeah i i agree with you because look
they're going to want to try to win you
put your best foot forward with the guy
you have yes that's right and then you
just adapt and adjust but uh this is all
pointing toward tuatanga villoa or some
equivalent quarterback next year and you
know the dolphins have gone through what
the steelers went through between terry
bradshaw and ben roethlisberger from dan
marino 20 years later you don't have a
franchise quarterback it's hard to be a
consistent contender and that's what
we've seen out of miami and i think
their job number one it's easier said
than done find a franchise quarterback
all right last topic for today chris and
you know we know the preseason's meaning
listen people complain about the
preseason being meaningless and it
really doesn't matter who wins and loses
these games and at one point i actually
suggested if we want to make the
preseason even marginally relevant use
pre-season record as
the the tiebreaker right above coin toss
you know there's ten other tiebreakers
but at least put it on there so at least
give it some and people go crazy when
you suggest that so it's meaningless so
why am i reading quotes from john
harbaugh and trace mcsorley the rookie
jack of all trades in baltimore that
they've got a 16 game preseason winning
streak in baltimore and it actually
means something it doesn't mean anything
why is anyone putting any significance
whatsoever why do they even read the
scores of the games except for the
degenerate gambles gamblers nobody cares
about who wins and loses in the
preseason and i don't care if the ravens
have won 16 in a row if you really want
to win 16 in a row it's not all that
hard to win 16 in a row because
typically the other team doesn't care if
they win or if they lose yeah no you
know again i think the big picture thing
is it's not like oh gosh we're killing
it in the preseason but still coaches
and players want to win those preseason
games they do it it gives a better vibe
even though it's meaningless and i know
it's meaningless to the fans and to the
big picture of the season and all that i
think of the very
basic fundamentals of it though i do
look at it like this as the baltimore
ravens it just is it shows you john
harbaugh his leadership they go out
there and compete and they're physical
and they're the bulgies on the field and
even though the preseason's basic we
know that the ravens are one of those
teams mike that i always say if a bar
fight broke out with 32 teams in the nfl
the ravens are going to be in the final
four or five i can promise that when
they come off the bus you go holy crap
look at this team whoa look at that big
sucker whoa look at that big sucker and
you just keep saying that and i think
that's where in the basic preseason
games where there's not a lot of like
trickery and schematics it kind of just
shows that they're the bigger more
physical team on a on a week-to-week
basis in pre-season football
you know it's funny last week when big
cat was on we had a draft of the head
coaches we would want with us heading
into a fight and we didn't even mention
john harbaugh oh she should have yes
he's looking
he has spent a lifetime with a smile on
his face he has spent a lifetime
fighting jim yeah right he's a guy who
would be ready to scrap at the drop of a
hat no doubt i still i i still
that means
you're right this but listen to the
quote from trace mcsorley i think it
means a lot at the end of the day
winning is what matters coach haubaugh
preaches winning all the time and and uh
you know i've seen the club the team
like after the vikings beat the seahawks
the other night the guys from the
vikings run across the field waving
goodbye to the seahawks i mean you know
i guess you're in uniform and it feels
like a game and you get caught up in it
right if you get caught up in playing
pick up basketball that's not meaningful
you get caught it's competition that's
right that's what it is and it is
setting a culture a little bit you know
it is winning all the time and i'm sure
harbaugh compete compete compete we want
to be the tougher team and the team buys
into that uh more times than not and i
think there is something to respect
about that aspect of it even though i do
agree with you it really doesn't mean a
whole lot in the big picture of things
and remember this as our friends in
detroit well know the 2008 lions were
4-0 in the pre-season and then went on
to go oh and 16. that's right in the
regular season all right our pre-season
is ending we're on the same track as the
nfl and we will be there in soldier
field in 13 days when things get rolling
packers bears we'll be back monday with
another pft live we'll be updating
everything all weekend long at
profootballtalk.com sims i expect some
clicks from you baby you know what
you're checking us out we'll keep you up
to date on everything i live there don't
you worry i lived there before you gave
me this job but i still live there so
don't worry about it
all right everybody have a great weekend
we'll see you on monday see ya
all right buddy
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports